oh hi everybody
Hey look here what do you know uh uh
dodge that moose man walking the halls
and found this little old book sitting
in this bookshelf here but how is weird
huh okay so thank you um
person I forgot who the name was I try
to remember the names of people but that
your usernames are all so silly
it's like Seabiscuit 100 101 yolo swagg
99 I can't keep up with it anymore
so anyway I went too far so I got a key
and this key unlocks the hatch which is
up in the ceiling of this place hi baby
Bob baby I got I gotta go I gotta get
away baby I gotta go I gotta fly away I
forget the rest
so anyway carrying on oh and sorry to
disappoint everyone I actually have
never watched Doctor Who I just know a
lot of references of it till a lot of
people do so I'm not a fan of Doctor Who
or anything I just know he had two
heartbeats
and he's got the magic blue box that's
bigger on the inside than it is on the
outside just like my underwear
nevermind no I said that okay here we go
so we got a key found in an old book oh
no oh yes I'll go down here this looks
good I'm sliding I'm sliding I'm not
sliding I am not even able to get down
there I'm not even able to go what the
hell this is baloney you gotta be
kidding me
ah you got it oh you all I swear
Oh uh-huh
ah there [ __ ] away holy balls
Jesus oh hello are you a know your I
know that sound as it sounded some
cultists to chant in there who's here oh
now you can't come up here just try it
I'm Way up here you're way down there
you go do your pathfinding I'm guessing
that your purpose of being down there is
scripted so you just go on your merry
way and I'll stay up here and you can go
fat your self okay what are you doing
what are you doing what are you doing
what is he doing what is he doing what
are you supposed to do I guess I'm
supposed to go let's go let's go let's
go Oh
ha ha [ __ ] oh yeah who's the greatest I
am you're not even following me oh oh oh
no wait a minute
ah oh no oh no no no this is success
there's the same bloody thing
where'd he go wait a minute there must
be like a switch or something over here
that um helps me get the other side oh
hello
oh wait you're just in there are you
doing all right screw it I'll be on fire
I see the shard oh boy
Oh anyway oh wait all right all right
Oh for me I don't know
huh ah-hah he's still here where do I go
what do I do
let's all bone it you know I you get
boned her get boxed hey I got no more
funds get get faced ha ha didn't it okay
so um he's gonna be wandering over there
a little bit while I see over here hey
buddy
hi friend how about you go over there
look you can't find me I'm so hidden so
well hidden in this dark corner I heard
that I heard that chase noise don't
think you can keep that chase noise away
from me in there alright for some reason
I have a piece of the orb now I'm gonna
go back cuz I think that I may have
forgotten something our thumb [ __ ]
no I guess I could get away from me if I
climb back up and go around and then do
the other thing with the other thing and
go sideways upside down maybe I don't
know I don't know there's nothing else
is here is there ha ha ha [ __ ]
well right now I'm going back
oh yeah Oh what yeah you can't find me
good stay there
get get [ __ ] oh I did not expect him
to be there oh man he was not about to
be there ah yeah okay I got four pieces
osorb oh no oh no I tried myself in here
Hey look out oh that's so great let's
get out of here okay okay
so magically mysteriously my scream oh
no oh no my weird screaming has forgot
to replace the branch oh god I call to
the heavens
look at him squirming down there it's so
funny it's good guy good ah okay so
where is this dick now where is he what
the hell
Jesus get out of your burrow come on
bring it [ __ ] oh what's that oh yeah
I'm over here oh yeah yeah come at me
hahahaha faked you out oh so hard
hey have the greatest I'm so great oh
the bridge is still down
I forgot don't kill that okay quickly
quickly quickly quickly quick
[Music]
okay I gotta wait patiently as he gets
in the room and then I go by him just
also sneakily oh so sneakily I'm bad at
this okay I just gotta
oh so snake ously let me just get in
position here so I not he doesn't see me
who come on I don't want to jump he's
gonna hear me like a shadow
doesn't know I'm here does he oh yes he
does
you don't know I'm here Sun Moon over
Kailash floor don't die again yes ah no
why oh that was up ah
Loney uh-huh you gotta be joking me
ah that was up I couldn't run out any
time fudge all right anyway um okay then
I guess oh whoa I do now I'm still at a
loss as to my current objective sir or
madam whoever will whoever designed this
game okay so obviously ah boss
oh oh just breathe I'll bring it and I
bring it I mean don't bring it here but
over there rather over in that area
would be a good place to bring any sort
of thing you would want to bring I'd
like a shadow of the night like a shadow
in the night leg is all right John the
night
and the greatest he awoke with a start
when the ship rocks suddenly against a
hard wave his heart pounding painfully
he tried to calm himself remembering how
far he wasn't from England but would he
ever feel truly safe would Miniver
Castle even be enough to protect him
from the shadow Middleburg Castle isn't
that does Brandenburg Brandenburg is
where ah back here again seems like
forever okay I've got all the arms from
this area correct maybe it's because I
have two lanterns that it's using up
twice as much oil it could be it okay I
got all the orbs all orbs I still lock
so why is I be back here yeah maybe I
got to go back to Sam you owe the
elevator no that's correct
the elevate or brush Samuel just stuck
there oh yeah and I can finally get this
pot of oil
please tell me that's the elevator I
finally yeah I love that there a long
time ago at least you see it was like
okay nevermind I'm okay
I'll just chillax right here Brad right
here Bray great here Bri not chillax in
the light like a shadow in the light
okay where is he I got a face up face
him like I hate the lever it didn't work
lever did not work
oh it's just sucks huh talks guys tell
my all good he let me keep the oil oh
yes jelly that's just silliness
I keep getting killed by these guys it's
not fair not fair I'm too pro oh it's
dark
wow it's really dark okay I just
wandered through the pitch blackness
yeah more pitch blackness is he still
there
I don't see him alright cuz she's clear
let's see if there's a work this time Oh
clunk clunk ah I should have turned it
up crank it huh Maureen had been badly
burned a portion of the East Wing had
collapsed I read that already
Hey no he could not allow moraine to
touch it again
oh nice music that's not gonna last
that's not gonna last at all where am I
now
Oh what the hell whoa those are some
weird-looking textures yeah buddy yeah
buddy okay some sort of sure oh hello
baby oh so good to see you again I'm
glad you made it out of there safely
babe all right got some privacy
whoo okay we're done sorry
okay um now I guess we go over here too
[Music]
outside I emerged from the church onto
the streets of London but it was a
little solace but it was little sauce I
knew they would keep hunting me I went
the only place I could to one place
mentioned in one of their documents wire
forest fire first the location of the
last two hearts Charles Longden chapter
five gosh there's only two chapters left
after this so three chapters in total
can five six and seven wow these are
some custom trees fire forest looks very
interesting
however fire forest was going to have to
vie thank you everybody so much for
watching click the annotations for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you also write in any pertinent
information for the next chapter in the
description in the comments book I will
see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]